quarterback's the most important and
influential position in the game of
football you know it's funny Chris and
other sports greatness seems to be
celebrated across team lines in football
greatness has you celebrated by the fans
of the team you play for and resented by
everyone else it is really difficult for
a quarterback to be popular on a broad
basis and I think that a great
quarterback that happens to play for a
bad team is more likely to be popular
than another quarterback that plays for
a great team because your ultimate ly
threatened by great teams if you're a
fan of a team and so you're ready said
who are the most popular quarterbacks in
the NFL from the standpoint of
likability popularity guys that we don't
say oh I hate him right yeah and this is
this is a great discussion or topic okay
so I mean obviously I think the most
popular quarterback is Tom Brady right
but I think that it's not always
positive popular so I think there's a
lot of people that are sick in New
England and they look at Tom Brady and
oh my gosh he yells on the sidelines and
see and yells let's go before the game
and it's so troubling oh my gosh show
them they hate him you know how dare he
complains when he gets hit and yells and
gets sacked and he gets mad how dare he
so then they get mad at him for that too
so Brady to me is the most popular but I
don't know is necessarily the most love
most loved Mike I think right now is
Patrick mahomes I don't know how you
feel there's other guys that are great
but great nobody seems that not like
Patrick mahomes right now I agree with
you completely and they didn't win the
Super Bowl see that that resentment
doesn't build yet for the Chiefs they
didn't even get to the Super Bowl so not
that they were a bad team and that's
what I think Baker Mayfield has
fascination for now I think there's
there's some some leonis a part of fans
of other teams thinking okay this Baker
may feel things gonna get out of hand
and he's gonna start kicking the butt of
my favorite team on a regular basis I'm
not gonna like him very much but I kind
of like him for now because it's kind of
neat to see this story so I think
Mayfield could become popular quickly
but it could also become resented
quickly and you mentioned Brady he is
the best-selling athlete from a
merchandise standpoint in the National
Football League he's at number one how
how can anyone who doesn't already have
I mean you can't already have your Brady
Jersey are you cycling through your
third or fourth generation of Brady
Jersey hasn't worn out and you need to
go buy another one yes I could change in
their uniforms every other year no it's
amazing to me that he's still number one
but that's coming from the people who
love the Patriots and there are a lot of
them they intensely love Brady and that
balances out those who intensely hate
him yeah you're right and to answer your
question about the jerseys I mean my
little boys on his second Brady Jersey
cuz why he grew out of the first one so
it's still Tom Brady and he doesn't give
a damn that he's 42 he still wants a
Brady Jersey so he gets a bigger size
but yeah it's it's it's unbelievable
from that standpoint you know deshaun
Watson okay that's another guy I'll
throw into the conversation where I feel
like just about everybody likes him at
this point and we see the potential and
he's got a great way about him the
charisma all of that hey Cam Newton is
very popular but there is that hate
factor Aaron Rodgers of course very
popular but there is that hey there's
that hate factor yeah I mean then how
popular is he beyond Packer fans no see
I agree with you here - ah Watson fits
the the formula I was talking about
earlier a great quarterback on a team
that is widely regarded is
non-threatening yeah standpoint am i
high the Texans on will still beat them
deshaun Watson is a great guy great
quarterback fun to watch i aughtta mele
don't have to worry about the Texans oh
like I would have to worry about the
Patriots or the Packers right yeah no I
think you're right and you're right most
of the I think the attention Packer and
Aaron Rodgers gets what is not
necessarily fair is is negative I think
you know he's really popular because I
don't think anybody can deny that he's
you know in the conversation for one of
the three best quarterbacks in football
so that's where he's popular but yes
people love to blame all the Packer
struggles on him and then you know two
players out of the thousands that he
played with they said they didn't like
him he's not a good teammate so that
gets becoming this story so you're right
I mean he's not a positive popular but I
still think he's very popular because of
the way he plays I look at that you know
hey Russell Wilson where do we put him
in this you know Russell Wilson I feel
like everybody likes them I don't feel
like everybody loves them some people
think Russell Wilson's you know a little
cheesy or a hokey because he's you know
just does everything the right way go
Hawk says it's so professional I feel
like that's where the heat comes from
Russell Wilson but it's not real
hey that's almost just like all we don't
love you as much as the other guys
there's a goody-two-shoes element to
Rusty because the fact that so many guys
in his own locker room resented him for
it it makes it hard to get people to
warm up to it but you know what the
public is pretty good about smoking out
yes a suspected phone enos although look
I I I'm a Russell Wilson guy but I can
understand why some people have issues
with Russell Wilson because sometimes it
does feel a little bit forced and a
little bit contrived and the bottom line
is the better the quarterback is the
better his team is the more you're gonna
hate him it's not a matter of popularity
maybe it's it's respect but I'm with you
I think right now it's Patrick mahomes
yeah because of the influence he's
having on youth throughout America
trying to throw no-look pass as I roll
with their left hand when they're not
left-handed and do all sorts of crazy
funny body throws and one foot on the
ground no feet on the ground falling
down doing whatever and throwing an
accurate pass he's gonna be a very
positive influence on young people he's
got a great platform and I think he'll
yeah I have no doubt that who used it
the right way but I think he's the guy
even even with Mayfield rising I think
mahomes is the guy that's gonna become
the the most popular quarterback in the
NFL if he's if he isn't already yeah no
I agree and it's just it's an
unbelievable era we're in right now III
just that's one thing I hope everybody
can appreciate because we man do we got
a lot of good quarterbacks we are seeing
you know the the we're bearing the
fruits of 30 years of the NFL being the
most popular sport in America and all
the best athletes and everybody wants to
play quarterback and man do we got a lot
of young talented and older talented
ones too we didn't even talk about drew
Brees where's Drew Brees in this
conversation because I feel like
everybody respects Drew Brees I don't
feel like anybody hates them but yet I
don't feel like the love is as high as
the other ones that maybe we love hey
hey we got a new crop of quarterbacks -
Kyler Murray is a guy who becomes very
popular very quick and docile his
playing style yes I mean there's a lot
of young quarterbacks out there they're
gonna be both loved and hated when their
teams are successful
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports